Hello,
and welcome to the newly branded Rawkode Academy.
This is my first
ever video
under this new name, and I I hope
you're excited to join me on this journey.
Remember, if you're not subscribed
already,
go ahead and do that now.
You can click thumbs up on the video,
plus helps other people find it. And now
you can join for under a dollar as
a monthly membership and get access to private
livestreams,
emojis,
although
they don't work that great on my software,
but we'll fix that.
And there'll be courses launching in July.
Also, we have a Discord server available at
Rawkode.chat.
If you're watching this live and wanna chat
afterwards or you have more questions, that is
the best place to do it. If you're
not watching live and you still have questions,
that is also the best place to do
it. Hopefully, we will see you in there
soon.
Now, today's episode is a little bit different
and that, well, it is just me.
And we're gonna do some CKA
exam preparation.
And I was really looking forward to this
until I read that it's apparently harder
than passing the CK.
You see here difficulty.
This simulator is more difficult than the real
certification.
So what is this simulator? This is Keller.
Sh.
This is now something that anyone who purchases
an exam from the CNCF
will have access to this simulator.
I believe they get two runs through the
scenarios in order to prepare for setting the
actual CTA.
So, of course, it makes sense that this
would be a little bit more difficult just
to give you that extra bit of confidence
when you go in for your exam.
So that's today's plan.
I have already started a a session.
In order to do so, if you wanna,
you know, do this in your own time,
you log in. I authenticated with my Linux
foundation account.
And then from the dashboard,
you can see I've got my active session
here and I have another one here.
It took around three minutes for the environment
to spin up.
I haven't looked at anything. I've not even
clicked star.
I believe I've got thirty six hours from
the moment I started the environment to complete
it.
So we're pretty much just gonna
dive straight in and and see how prepared
I am.
My
CKA and my CKAD both expire in a
couple of months, so this will be really
good preparation
for resetting those exams.
So if you're watching, say hello in the
comments. It's always good to get a little
bit of feedback, especially when I'm sitting here
all on my own.
And let's get started.
Actually, nervous.
Alright. Let's see.
Zoom. Zoom. Zoom. Zoom. Let's make this really
big. Hopefully, that's oh.
It's difficult for me to read, but
let's see how we get on.
Okay. Instructions. You should avoid using
the deprecated kubectl commands as these might not
work in exam.
There are three Kubernetes clusters and eight nodes
in total. Cluster one, cluster two, cluster three.
Got it.
I'm only allowed to have one other browser
tab open with the Kubernetes documentation.
I'm not gonna read the docs.
Notes.
You have a notepad tool,
Just like the exam.
And there's a difficulty thing. Alright.
Using kubectl from the terminal, you can reach
the API servers of all of them. I
just need to switch context. Alright. Good.
What did I do?
Oh, next question.
First
challenge done.
Okay.
I have access to multiple clusters from my
main terminal.
Sure.
Kubectl context, right, all of these context names
enter this fail.
You have access to multiple clusters for your
main terminal for the kubectl. Alright. Kubectl.
Got it.
Let's see.
Config get
contacts.
Yep.
Write all those context names and to a
fail. Alright.
One in each lane, comma separated.
Do you care?
Not sure.
Alright. Let's do a head
dash m one. It should get rid of
the header. No. That's only gonna give me
the header.
Did I skip a lane?
Told tell me I can't remember how to
skip a lane.
Manhead.
Okay. Print the first number of lanes. No.
I wanna skip a lane. Skip a lane.
Skip a lane.
Alright.
Who just thought that would get me first?
Get
context. I'm just going to
arc
open open
Print.
One.
Why have I got a thingy here?
Now zero would be the whole lane. One
should be the star. Two should be the
name.
Alright.
Write this to
op
course
one
context,
and I'm gonna cheat because I can't remember
how to skip a line on my output.
Maybe I could do with less.
Of course, one
tail. Thanks, Alex.
That's always a weird thing. Alright. I think
that's good enough.
So Alice Bauer says, yeah, should have used
tail. Yeah, I can. I could have used
tail. It seems obvious now that you've stated
it.
Matt Hawk, I'm a huge Hawk fan. I
love using Hawk for pretty much anything on
my terminal.
Okay, so now we want to write a
command to display
the current context
and here,
I would just hit that.
Alright, so
get context.
Correct.
Star.
Yep.
Put it into this other file.
Sure thing. I just want a name.
Yep.
Print
to
opt
course one.
Bring up my CLI a bit. No problem,
Navin. Thank you.
Alright. Context
default
kubectl
dot sh.
Oh, wait. It says write a command
to display the current context.
Alright. So I don't sort of command in
the file, even though it's dot sh file.
Yeah, I want that SH trail to be
a command that I could run right.
Without the use of kubectl.
Really?
Okay.
Echo
all of this.
I think that's what it wants.
I'm assuming the idea being I could run
course
one context
default.
I got the rate.
Why did my
walk not kick in?
Because it was interpolated.
There we go.
That was funny.
Okay. Now I need to do the same,
but without
using cube control. So I expect what this
is trying to confirm is that I know
that the config is here.
That is Yamal.
Always grip fail. It has a default context
lane if I remember or a current context
lane.
Correct.
Current.
Yeah. There we go.
So we actually wanna echo this to fail,
and I know someone's gonna tell me, you
don't need to use cat. Yeah.
That's that's gonna bug me, isn't it? So
Okay. So we're gonna grab for current here.
Okay,
so now our arc has to get fancy.
And because we do want to print
zero all one left hand side, two right
hand side, only this time we're gonna need
an
a field separator.
I'm getting nested quotes here now. I wonder
if I can do it with the, let's
try.
And I'm gonna have to run this to
test before I start echoing it.
No. Alright. Okay.
Now if this is field separator, go in.
There we go.
Alright. So now I wanna echo this
to that location,
escaping these.
I don't know if I completely misunderstood
this first task. It seems a little weird,
but I should
be able to run
context
default
null.
My awk again.
It's a good thing I'm checking my work.
Alright.
We've got a cube control one, make sure
that works. It does. And we wrote our
context.
Not what I was expecting for a first
question.
I guess it's just trying to clarify, you
know, where the cube things is, you know,
roughly the format of what,
how the context works and how it stores
the default. And then I guess there's a
little bit of knowledge there to test your
cube control.
Alex with another great comment in the chat.
Cube control get context. No headers.
Yeah.
There we go.
I always forget that's an option.
Yeah.
I agree, Matt. I'm not entirely sure that
it's a great first question,
but
Alex, what you're saying to me. Alex is
saying, I don't think you did the context
one correctly.
Since it wants you to know what the
options are.
No. I think that would be a shitty.
I don't think it's anything to do with
the options. I I think it's just familiarity
with the KubeConfig and enough Linux knowledge to
juggle it around. I don't really think it
matters how they get to it. Like,
knowing that you can do formatting of kubectl,
nobody remembers those parameters ever. Everyone's always gonna
default. I will speak for myself, not for
everyone. I'm always gonna default to my Linux
tools rather than esoteric flags on kubectl.
So I disagree. The outcome is what matters.
Okay. I switched context. I create a single
pod running this image and the namespace default.
The pod should be in pod one, and
the container should be named pod one container.
This pod should only be scheduled on a
control plane node. Do not add any labels.
Shortly, write the reason on why the pods
are by default not scheduled.
Okay.
Now,
do we have anything well, I'm gonna set
my alias.
Have anything running to copy.
I always found that it's the best way
to get started when I did my CK
the first time. Like, nobody expects you to
remember a pod spec off the top of
your head. I thought the pod's
easy enough. We probably could we probably could
take that up.
But there's already specs here and this is
a one to one cluster.
Was it?
Let's find out.
Which means if I do a get pod
dash o
yaml,
there must be a one.
No, no,
no. There we go.
No. Yeah. It's not got all of the
verbosity that I just bet. So, okay, cool.
I didn't see managed fields, which is good.
This maybe has a one twenty one cluster.
There
used to be an export flag, don't think
that works anymore. Yeah. That was deprecated, but
it would try to remove all of that
crap.
But you can just say pod dot yaml
and
then tweak.
So you gotta remember to remove metadata that
is not particularly important.
And I also told us that there should
be no labels.
Do not add any new labels to the
node.
Okay. Means I don't need any.
The name is supposed to be
pod one and the default namespace.
We
don't need that.
Containers. Unfortunately, think that's actually the same one,
isn't it? Yep. 2, no, almost.
2.40.41DashAlpine.
The policy is not important. The pod name
was, I want it to be called Pod
1 container.
We don't need any mounts if I delete
too much. Nope.
Where's my relative line numbers?
What else do we need?
Nothing
yet.
We will need the toleration, I'm gonna leave
them in.
And I can't comment about Oh, yeah, can't
This is an actual local fail. This is
not a cube control edit.
I'll never remember the toleration syntax.
And we'll delete all of that. Okay.
This is our polyaml spec.
Right now I think it does everything that
it has to do here.
It wants us
to ensure that is only scheduled on a
control plane node,
which means
I need to remember how all of this
works,
but we can run KGET nodes.
Let me shut my phone up.
Describe
cluster
one, master
one.
And
there is label on this, which will say
that it is a control plane node, although
we could just use a node selector.
Maybe that's just easier.
We've tried to tolerate
the labels,
but yeah, we got this here. So we
can either add a toleration
or this load,
affinity for this label,
but I'm just gonna use the node selector
actually.
Where was that? What was it? Okay. Cluster
one,
master one. Okay.
In a while. Let's see.
Bye.
What
did I get wrong?
Oh, my node selector is wrong.
Alright, we are gonna use Kubernetes docs. Node
selector.
That's what I used.
I put it in the wrong place.
Alright. Okay. So yeah, it's the node selector
and then how to select it.
I don't think we need to use affinity
here. I'm going to just avoid it.
And just need name.
Let's try.
So worst that can happen.
Only people are watching me.
Alright. Node selector.
Well, that pending tells me
hasn't worked.
Zero free notes are available to pod and
tolerate.
Okay.
It didn't match that. So
my selector is wrong. Let's describe
this again.
That are the key, get nodes, show labels.
Okay. What we got?
How does this work again?
Oh yeah, good show.
Rory is saying I can just use node
name.
Now I'm kinda,
I do kinda wanna get it working.
So the node selector, and then there's this,
is this, this is the key value pair,
right? Of the labels that were attached because
this is
adding a label here where this type equals.
So I'm assuming,
we'll try one more thing and I'll use
node name and one US actually set the
node name on the pod. I believe the
scheduler just ignores it and then the kubelet
takes over. So you don't it doesn't get
scheduled per se.
But that's a good show actually.
Okay. So we did have control plane,
but it was set to kind of zero.
So I'm assuming
control dash plane here with an empty file
and I can't update pods. Those are immutable.
See, I've made this take a lot longer
now by just avoiding
the affinity. I think the affinity would have
been a lot quicker,
but
yeah, okay, that's not working.
Delete pod, pod one.
Let's modify this one more time.
Cluster one.
Here we go. So
what's the chat saying to me? It was
kinda going
kinda Alastair saying, hey.
If you're telling me to use tents, yeah.
I was avoiding that just because I felt
like it was too much typing and then
it ended up taking myself around on a
couple of circles.
So suggestion, well, you need a toleration for
the no schedule. Not if I skipped the
scheduler and use node name.
Oh, yeah. Actually, I bet my selector was
working and I just didn't tell it to
tolerate the no schedule.
There we go.
In fact, there we go. If got comments
in the chat. You forgot to add the
toleration.
Message is quite difficult to read. Let's pop
that over there.
Let's just remove that.
The opacity or transparency.
Okay. Let's see.
Alright. Yep. The chat corrects me. Yes. You're
all correct.
Awesome.
However,
we cheated. Well, it's not cheating. We got
the end result. Maybe it's just not the
way that we're telling us to. And the
CK is not, I don't think they check
to see how you implemented that. They really
just check the results.
You use whatever you can.
Okay.
So
switch con it's the same context, but let's
type it anyway or copy and paste it
anyway.
Okay. There are two pods
and a namespace
project c 13
or o three DB.
There are indeed.
C 13 management asked,
just asked us to scale them down so
that we only have one replica.
Okay. So the first thing we notice here
is the naming convention of the pod.
It is not a triple with a replica
set in the middle like we see here.
So this this is the three part triple.
Pods are generally like this. This would be
the higher level name, probably the deployment.
The middle bit is the replica set ID
and then this is the pod ID.
What we see here is that
these are stateful sets because we have numbered
ordered pods.
Oh, did I miss an action on question
two?
Did I?
Oh, yeah. Sure. Thanks. Good catch.
So I'm gonna lie here.
The pods weren't scheduled
with the affinity
or
selector
because the pod wasn't configured
to tolerate
the taint
that control plane nodes
have.
Not sure how they check that if a
human is involved or they just look for
the keyword, which is tolerate, but there we
go. Okay, so we wanna scale down the
stateful set. So if we enter namespace,
get
STS,
You can see it here.
Edit o three DB
replicas
one
get pod
watch.
And we'll wait for that to terminate and
we'll move on.
I think we're good.
More questions like that, please.
Okay, same context. I'm not going to copy
and paste it again. Do the following,
do the following and namespace default, create a
single pod named ready of service ready with
an NGINX image, configure aliveness probe,
which simply runs true,
configure a readiness probe, which does an HTTP
check.
Start this pod and confirm it isn't ready
because of the readiness probe.
Alright. Well, we already got a pod Yamo.
What question is this?
Let's call it q four.
It was naive of me to call it
pod.yaml
in the first place.
Okay. So
pod name
ready.
If service,
Default namespace.
Doesn't need scheduled.
Image nginx one sixteen one dash
Alpine.
Oh, come on then.
Let's just call this
NGINX.
Okay. So
we need to add
liveness
probe
command.
See if I can remember how to do
this. I'm gonna use the docs.
So there's two ones that can go here,
right? There's http get
blah blah blah.
And
I think it's
just exec
and then
true.
We'll make it up there. Okay.
Oops.
Remember when I said I wasn't gonna use
a docs? Well, that was naive to exec
command.
So close.
Alright.
And this is just returning true.
Okay.
And it wanted a
readiness probe
get
URL
Copy paste.
It's actually telling me to
use w get.
Why?
We get Oh, because that's only gonna Of
course.
Because you can't provide an absolute URL here.
It only hits your actual pod.
Of course it is.
Okay. So
I'm feeling to be able to do. Let's
do the exact
command.
This is actually a
list.
As is this, I'm gonna change syntax just
to make it confusing for everyone.
W get
this.
Okay. So start the pod, confirm that it
never gets ready because of this command here.
Q four.
Okay. So that is running,
and we should not really see any updates
for that to change.
May have been smart for me to set
it then really quickly so we can get
through the three adaptations, but I'm pretty confident
that is not gonna update because I trust
the exam question.
Okay. So now we wanna create a second
pod called I am ready. Looks like the
image is potentially the same. We want to
add a label.
They already exist in service service. I'm not
ready. It should now have that second. Okay.
So now we're just checking that we can
add a new pod with the right label,
which is going to be in the selector
in our service.
We'll call this Q4,
Q 4 2.
So what was different here? Am I ready?
Yes. Am I ready?
Some of the default namespace is correct.
Image is the same.
Labels.
That's the labels on that.
Yeah, it's just apologies about deployment.
Labels
ID
cross
server ready.
Doesn't ask for any probes.
Running, ready,
describe.
Let's get the services first.
Describe service.
I have a quick No.
Let's get that enabled next.
And
we have our endpoint.
Looking good.
Alright.
Source.
Control
completion
bash.
Cool.
Alright.
Like that one.
Question five.
It says I've got ninety three minutes left.
I'm only gonna be streaming for another thirty.
So we'll see how far we get through
and then I'll try and pick it up
again
after I've had lunch with my daughter.
Okay. Same context.
There are various pods in all namespaces. No
shit. Write a command into fame pods, which
was all the pods sorted by their age.
Who
remembers
this?
Alex is gonna give me any trouble if
I don't use
commands, but
more like this through bash and sort and
stuff.
So first thing we want to do is
get all pods
wide.
Do we even need,
we get the time already, don't we? Yeah.
Okay.
Get pods help. Let's do this nice way.
So
start by
I don't think these flags are good for
certification.
Not that important.
Network?
Yeah. They're not enough of that coder anymore.
Alright. And write the command into a file.
Okay.
Alt
course five.
Alright.
Right. Second command,
which lists all the pods sorted by
metadata UID using kubectl sorting for both commands.
Okay. So I was actually making sure I
used that.
So this is
find pods
UID
UID.
Thank you.
That's my other one.
Thomas laugh, nice catch. I forgot the all
pods
in my commands.
Alright. Let's run off course five fame pods
and find pods,
UID.
Alright.
Maybe I messed something up there. Seems okay.
Oh, 8%.
Okay.
Create a new persistent volume
named Safari PV. I should have a capacity
of two gigabit access
mode to readwrite once host path. Hey.
And no storage class name defined.
Create a new persistent volume claim
to claim the persistent volume.
Alright.
Let's see if we have any PVs, PVCs.
Definitely
copy and paste in this at the docs
then.
Okay.
Well, this is question
six
then
q six. I just need to create them.
I don't need to store the YAML anywhere.
Yeah. Nice.
Okay. So we'll just do this all in
a one hour. Q six dot YAML.
Copy some YAML.
Assistant
volume.
Show me the ammo.
Got one with everything?
No.
K. One at a time.
Messed my Versus Code Editor, which has OO
Complete and generation for all of this.
Okay. What are we calling this?
Safari
PV
two, read write once.
Don't need anything else.
Yama multi lane and that we need to
claim
as such.
And
we're calling this,
oh wait, host path here. I'll fix that
in a second.
Okay.
So,
oh no, we're in a namespace.
Safari
PVC
namespace.
Project Tiger, nice name.
Don't define the storage class name.
I don't want, don't need volume mode either.
And
how do we define host path?
Just a little path. Okay.
PostPath.
Volumes.
I don't know if that's supposed to be
a joke with it slash volumes capital V.
Maybe it's like trying to pretend it's a
Mac.
Never seen that on a Linux system before.
Alright. Let's make sure I've not messed this
up. So we created a persistent volume called
Safari PV.
It's got two Gebi bits.
Gebi bits.
We've got a host path of volumes data
with an access mode to read write once.
We then want a PVC within a namespace,
which we've got the same size, same mode,
no storage class.
Oh, and you want a deployment.
Am I gonna type a deployment?
Well,
guess we're converting a pod to deployment. Okay.
Deploy.
And we wanna call this
Safari
and same namespace.
Really I should have created some of these
first.
Yeah,
I should be using kubectl explain.
Okay.
Now we need to convert this pod to
deployment. So that goes away. We've got spec
template
spec
selector
and oh too much.
Oh, it's set.
TS, let's say you set a tab size.
Let me just do this the slow manual
way.
Why is that x four? X three?
So, yeah.
It's a small x.
Alright.
Okay.
Image.
I don't think care about the names.
So let's call this HTTP because it's the
image at least at once. That one's HTTP
two four four one
Alpine.
No command.
It wants to mount our PV, which would
leave a code.
This is a host path
and
it's going to fix that.
And we're mounting to
temp
Safari data.
Maybe it's a Mac joke. It's called Safari.
Alright. This volume
is
who knows?
The fatty
PVC.
Can't remember if it has claim name or
if it's something else.
Course, persistent volume claim and then the claim
name.
Persistent
volume
claim.
This could blow up.
I have no idea.
Draps.
It did blow up. Okay. Converting the channel
to JSON line 12.
I've got any more than that. I cannot
find expected colon.
Anchor saying
feels good to watch someone else think.
Thanks. I'm doing my best.
Okay.
Debugging at all is not something I want
to be doing.
Okay. So this, these
board dashes. I'm on chat. Should be all
over that.
At least now it's something else, but okay.
So it's telling me that my persistent volume
and valid type host path volume source got
a string expected to map.
Okay, what did I get wrong with the
host path?
Yeah, let's use the explain.
So this is our persistent volume spec host
path. So we can do k explain
PV spec
host path and
it just expects there to be a path.
Easy when you know how.
And let's try.
Silly
apps v one.
Alright. I
was gonna say better. I mean, that is
better.
I didn't add a selector.
Okay.
Labels,
name
Safari,
templates back.
Selector
match labels
name,
and
gonna get something wrong.
Name
Safari.
Quickly. Why is that? Don't have much time.
But it's not labels on the top level.
Right? Is it? Matadea labels.
Select
or match labels.
Method, oh, got it the wrong way,
Kinda.
Alright.
So this is the selector
match labels,
templates back,
metadata
label. Yeah, of course it is.
This is the, we applied to pods.
Spacing looks wrong.
Unknown field metadata.
I just looked you up.
Template spec.
Template spec metadata.
Template meta.
Yeah. This because
it's above that.
Like, I was actually typing a real pod.
Alright.
Let's
check.
This was a namespace, wasn't it? Projects
Tiger project.
Pvb.
Alright.
That is
perfect.
What I'm looking for here
is just these status
bound. That means they're connected, they're working.
What I don't wanna see is I get
pods and something set in impending because it
can't do anything.
All is good running.
We can always describe it if we were
cautious.
Tiger
describe pod. We should have auto complete.
Nope.
And
we got our volume.
Looks good.
Okay.
I think that's alright.
Okay. So I wonder how many questions there
are. I really should look that up because
I'm not sure what I'll get through. Maybe
maybe one or two more.
K. This is a one percenter, so the
matrix server hasn't been installed yet in the
cluster, but it's something that should be done
soon. Your college would already like to know
the kubectl commands too. Show
node
resource
usage.
Show pod under container. I mean, that's not
gonna work with the metric server.
Just want the command.
Sure. Why not?
Course
seven.
I don't know if it wants me
to install metric server.
It just wants the commands. Okay.
So this will be kubectl top node
pod.
Don't know if I'm oversimplifying
this one.
Well,
we'll just keep moving.
Yeah. But before I get to the end,
well, I think I can actually go in
the actions here and just say like, you
know, get my get my score.
So if we don't
Woah,
there's 25 questions
And I've got plenty of time but not
actually got plenty of time. So maybe
I think if I click show answers
and score,
I don't think I can come back and
do it again, but I do have thirty
six hours. So I'm tempted to just, you
know, do the next question and then maybe
just, like, drop out and then do a
part two.
But I also kinda wanna know if I'm
getting shit right.
Okay.
Let's see. Let's see where we are in
five minutes. Okay. So we wanna SSH in
to the master
why does it keep calling it master control
plane node?
SSH onto a control plane node with this.
Let me send a feedback to update that.
Come on. We're past this now.
Okay. Check how the control plane components keep
ah, see, I love it when I get
to deal with the control plane components.
I think it'd be, that's a clustered episode
right there.
Check how the mass control plane components, the
kubelet, the API server, the schedule and the
cube controller manager and SSE are starting and
installed on the control plane node. Also find
that name of the DNS application and how
it started Awesome.
This is just a
health check of the components.
So
what I would expect, in fact, we can
check if this is a QVDM cluster,
but just really take a look here. And
whenever I see admin.conf,
usually a really good indicator this is the
Kubernetes cluster, which means
we're gonna have our kubelet started via systemd,
which we do.
Next we check for the static
manifest paths.
You can see here, we've got etcd, API
server control manager scheduler, scheduler special
running.
And now we want to,
I think what it wants us to do
here is to know that we can do
admin dot conf as a way to query
cluster.
We can also do a get system, get
pods, and we're looking for the core DNS
pod or maybe it's kubed DNS, but I
don't know. Yeah. There we go. Core DNS.
Okay. Write your findings into this,
should be structured like so.
Let's copy it.
So opt
course
eight
master
component for text.
Alright.
So kubelet
systemd.
Pod?
Static pod?
Pathway.
Read the docs.
Not installed. Process. Static pod. Okay. Cool. Static
pod.
That's pod. That's pod. That's pod. Static pod.
And
pod
coordinates.
Even though the pods aren't actually called core
DNS,
the deployment is. I think that's okay.
Root.
Help.
Opt course.
Is it because I'm, does it want me
to do it in the SSH or does
it want me to do it on my
Yeah. Okay.
Let's grab my,
I think
it wants me to come out of the
SSH
course eight
master.
It should make that more clear. I could
trip people up.
Next.
Okay.
So,
oh, new context. Not the same context.
Hello, new cluster.
Okay,
Navin says that my kubelet type is not
systemd in process.
Thank
you.
I mean, I think I should get extra
points for writing systemd,
but
let's leave it like this.
Thank you for that. Good catch. Alright. 9.
We've already switched context.
We're gonna ask the station to cluster two,
cluster one.
Temporarily stop the cube scheduler.
Alright.
Is it a static manifest on this cluster?
It is.
So temporarily stop the kube scheduler, this means
in a way that you can start it
again afterwards.
So you don't want me to delete the
file?
This is a
pod.
There stopped.
Create as
we should confirm it stopped, really.
KubeConfig,
Kubernetes,
and
KubeSystem,
pods,
and we have the scheduler.
Okay. Create a single pod named manual schedule
of the image, confirm that it started but
not scheduled on any node. And now you're
at the scheduler and have all the power
manually schedule a pod on that. Okay. So
now this is one node name.
This is just showing that
every put the node name, the scheduler is
removed from all scheduling decisions,
bypasses almost everything and just does its thing.
So
pod.
Yaml.
I'm gonna type this.
V1.
Okay.
We'll go type scrappy.
Spec.
Containers.
Name.
Image.
Actually, t p d. It's gonna bug me.
Manage data.
Name.
Manual.
Schedule.
Okay. Let's get our kube control. We don't
wanna do it in that namespace. Apply our
pod.yaml.
Can I not even write a pod now?
Expect to the map and it got an
array.
Oh,
that's just me being silly.
Okay. So we should see
that it's pending and unscheduled.
Pods are immutable.
Can you change the
I wonder. Not everything's immutable. Most things
are immutable.
So let's try.
Yeah, immutable.
So let's
delete,
apply,
get
running.
Okay.
Start the kube scheduler again and confirm. Oh,
wait, did I miss a step?
No. Okay. Start the schedule again and confirm
the scheduler is running and then create a
second pod.
We call it manual two.
Manual schedule
without
the node name.
It should run on a worker because it's
been scheduled like a normal pod.
Okay. So move
here,
Play
to
get pods.
Maybe you just have to wait a minute
for the scheduler to come on
and schedule that.
There we go.
And it should be running on
worker.
But we can do it. Oh, wait. I'm
just gonna affect the Vogue SIM then. Okay.
We're just doing all wide
and we can see it is on worker
one.
Okay.
Oh, it's a six percenter and I've got
a few minutes left.
Oh, it's decision time.
Create a service account.
Again, if I can do it quickly. And
I'll just come back to that question.
Create daemon set.
Create deployment. Yeah, I mean I can do
that pretty quickly.
Give me something to just
create part. A lot of yaml have been
somewhere around on this.
Okay. You're estimating the thought information about this
context.
Answer five questions.
Yeah.
I'm not finding a question. I can do
it in a couple of minutes. So
I will let the chat decide. Do we
want my answers and score or am I
coming back to this later
with another hour and an attempt to complete
the last ten ish questions? Yeah. Sixty eight
minutes left. I'm probably a little bit behind
where I should be, I think and hope.
And it's just because I'm talking about it
as I do it and not just heads
down, but
I don't get any strong opinions. Who wants
to see my score and who wants me
to come back to this later?
I will give you thirty seconds.
Oh, thank you, Naveen, for
becoming a member. Appreciate that, man. Thanks.
Alright. Nobody's feeling too chatty.
Part two please, Thomas laugh.
Alright,
you got it.
Can I pause this?
Or once you start it, you start it.
What happens if I just close it? Yeah.
Let's let's find out. I I I'll just
leave.
Listen, I'm worried because there's no explicit
pause is that it's just gonna time out.
Alright. I've got I've already spoken to the
team at color
shell. I don't know what they call it,
color dot sh color dot shell.
They've given me
credits
to stream this.
So
what I'll do is I will have answers
and score,
but I will do a full one completely.
I'll set aside the full
two hours. We'll do it start to finish
just because there's no pause. This is gonna
time out an error. I don't think coming
back is actually gonna work,
But I will do this again.
Yes.
It just stops the countdown. Yeah. I mean,
that's what's gonna happen anyway because I don't
have time to finish it just now.
Where's my score?
I got a low score because I never
get through all the questions. But scenario one,
tick, tick, tick, tick.
What?
Rats.
So why did I get the stateful step
one wrong? I didn't maybe I misread a
question. I didn't know it wanted a record
of the skill then. So I just went
into the manifest and edit it to replicas
because I'm a bit of a a cowboy
that way, I guess. What I should have
done was a proper skill down event using
dash dash record, which actually adds it to
the audit log as a history or an
event on the stateful set saying why this
was skilled down. You can actually add a
message to it. Really good if you're not
an amateur like myself.
Okay. So yeah, I misread that. That's my
fault.
And this one, I have no idea scenario
four pod one is ready. Did I not
wait for it to be ready? Did I
get something wrong?
I'm not sure,
but at least I did get the majority
of it correct.
QControl top pod.
It did work. I ran it. Although we
didn't have a metrics server working.
Maybe I wanted it as a plural. I'm
not sure why I got that wrong.
We got scenario eight correct, which was just
understanding control plane components.
Scenario nine.
Woah, did I miss an entire thing?
Alright. Well, I'm unhappy with that. And then
I didn't actually get through any of the
others. Okay.
Well, that was our first attempt at the
color shell CTE exam preps.
I will set aside a complete two hours
at some point this week. So that will
be today, tomorrow, or Friday,
and we will come back and do this
from start to finish again, and I will
read the questions properly.
Stop being an amateur. But thank you for
joining me today. I hope this was useful.
Feel free to reach out to me on
Discord or Twitter. Let me know what else
you wanna see. But thank you to the
people that joined the academy.
It is nice and cheap. Join early, and
more content is coming soon. Thanks a lot,
everyone. I'll see you soon.